ian stewart showed no emotion whatsoever
as that guilty verdict was brought back
by the foreman of the jury here at
huntington crown court the jury had been
deliberating for a total of nine hours
and 50 minutes and in the past 20
minutes they were brought back into
court and stewart was asked to stand as
that verdict was delivered no emotion
from him whatsoever now this was a very
unusual case because from the very
outset on the first day of this murder
trial the jury were told by the
prosecuting counsel that the man in
front of them 61 year old ian stewart
was a convicted murderer they were told
that in 2016 he had murdered his fiancee
the children's author helen bailey so
they knew from day one of this trial
that he was a convicted murderer it was
that conviction in 2017 that resulted in
police detectives going back and looking
at the sudden unexplained death of his
wife diane stewart who was 47 in
2010 and everything unraveled from there
police detectives got involved uh it had
initially been put down as something
called sudden death in epilepsy she was
an epileptic but she'd only ever had
three epileptic fits in her entire life
he claimed that on the day she died that
he had returned from the shops to their
family property at bassingborn in
cambridgeshire and he had found her
slumped in the garden and he said he
immediately began giving her cpr for 10
minutes
then went down the road to a doctor's
house who was a neighbor and then
returned and resumed the cpr when he
couldn't find the doctor so some 25
minutes had passed before he even rang
999 the prosecution told the jury this
was all part of a plot and that she
hadn't had an epileptic fit he had
indeed killed her so in the past few
minutes the jury coming back with that
guilty verdict against ian stewart we'll
hear shortly from the detective
superintendent jerome kent who
investigated both murders but in the
meantime we can listen to part of the
police interview where officers are
putting this to stuart and he doesn't
respond
but she's not awake you didn't think
that she was breathing how did you check
if she was breathing
[Music]
she said
you didn't think she was breathing said
i've tried i've turned her to put her in
the recovery position
but i can't do it she's just flopped
back
can you describe to us
how you put her in a recovery position
or how you tried to
so that was the police interview part of
it with stewart when he was initially
arrested on suspicion of murder we can
hear now from the 999 call
that was made on the day in question
this is june 2010 he has found his wife
slumped in the garden he said we now
know he had murdered her this is the
emergency call he made
after some 25 minutes or so
she's in the garden she's she's
unconscious
okay are you with the patient now i'm
just indoors at the moment can you see
her from where you are yeah
how old is she please she's
she's 45 47.
is she awake no no she's not awake is
she breathing
is she breathing no i don't think so no
right you need to go and check on us sir
for me please i'm right beside her now
is she breathing no sir nice
so just to recap in the past few minutes
here at huntington crown court 61 year
old ian stewart guilty of murdering his
wife diane she was 47 years old and that
was in 2010 very shortly we will hear
from the detective superintendent jerome
kent who investigated both murders